各位同学大家晚安
来我把我的麦克风拉过来一下
来大家晚安
哇这个Peter你果然是资深的同学
我正想要我刚好看到这位同学在讲的这位东西
他说他做空小台在一分钟线
你做空的位置
我刚刚其实还仔细看了一下
你空在10点37分是这里
就是你空在这里
这个地方
然后呢
你说停损该怎么设定
这样讲好了
如果你做空的位置相对不利
不管你停损设哪里
多近多远都没有意义
因为你打从最一开始的出手
可能判断就有失准
我举个例子
来我们放很大来看
来你做空在10点37分就是这一根
那我们来到这根的前面
你看到的是这样子对不对
你看哦
力量从这边跌多长少
跌多长少
结果变成是突然间涨多
有没有
你做空在第一次从跌多长少
突然间变涨多的地方
光这一点
就是光看到你做空之前的前面这一根
这么大一根
其实心里就知道这一单失败的几率
本来就偏高
所以你是从结果才回来看你的答案
你才想说我应该要怎么做
没有在当下下单的时候
没有任何应该怎么做
对不对
所以你说你的停损
你说在哪里
画压力线等等
来
你做空在这边
我就问你好了啦
你说425有压力线
对不对
射尖尖的最高
438这边
然后你说后面被打上去
这里
打上去然后就下来
对吧
这样讲好了
你下单之前
这个是1K
对不对
你有看过
更大刻度的样子吗
所以现在是因为结果到了
你会有点惋惜
我觉得给这位林同学不要从结果往前看你要看的是看你下单当下的那个逻辑有没有符合你要的
我猜你应该是想要赌这个互换
就是这个420附近的互换
对吧
那我就要问你一件事情
这个互换
它是一个下面涨很多上来
满足了的互换
例如说价格
例如说像是
例如说这个
这个
下面涨很多上来
假设这边有东西
这边有压力支撑
是这样子的互换呢
支撑转压力
还是是一个跌很多
正在上涨过程中
对吧
所以你要想的是
如果你手这边后面涨上去
你会不会现在回来说
庆幸我的防守是短短的
对吧
所以不能用结果回来看
这样好不好
所以这个
我只能跟你说
你目前看到的点
问题不在停损上
但是问题在哪里
这可能还要更多的
我需要更了解你的交易
你前面的思考逻辑
你为什么
例如说你为什么在这里看EK
你是根据5分K吗
15分K的涨像吗
还是哪里的涨像
做出这样子的决定
那这个我觉得要讨论的太多
所以我这一题就暂时先回答到这边
就略过了
这样好不好
那
我今天有做小那
但是等一下我来讲
放大优点是不是比砍掉缺点来的简单的多
嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯
放大优点
理论上是
就跟例如说
你很擅长数学
但是你英文很不好
那没有关系啊
你就把你的数学发扬光大
就大概是这种概念
那你要把不好的英文补起来
你可能要花两倍三倍五倍的时间
才能得到跟数学一样的成果
这样子
好不好
那这个我觉得应该放在各个行业
各种领域应该
求学阶段也是
然后工作也是
例如说我就
很不会打篮球
所以你叫我去打篮球
我应该会被撞飞
这样大概就是这种概念
但是我觉得你想太多的你就喜欢的事情就做就对了你想太多了好不好这个Larry同学
因为字比较多
我截起来看一下
第二口喷
如果他没有喷出的是
比较稳定慢慢的往右上
出场的时机大概是什么时候
要是我跟你讲
你爽的时候
你现在会骂我对不对
真的啊
如果你觉得比较大黑K下来是否该直接出场
那就出啊
出了以后喷出怎么办
就挨一下 哎呀 可恶 骂一下脏话
好 就去睡觉 不然怎么办
对不对 来讲到这个
所以你也是因为看到结果才回来
好像说我应该要怎么调整我的交易
不用 不用什么调整
你都是看到结果才回来调整
这没有意义
你怎么调都不一样
例如说你这一次
假设突然间跑掉
行情来到这边
你跑掉掉下来
你觉得很棒
我以后就这么做
就下一次稍微起来的
你又觉得好像要下来的
结果你一出噴出去
噴这么远
那该怎么办
再下一次你到底要不要凹
再下一次到底要怎么样
没有人知道
所以最好的就是宽心做好计划
你都已经出了一个短单了
那长线的就丢给他
就照着你原来的计划
只要那个计划还在翻亚当的范围内
那就合理
你不要跟我说
你持有一个1分K的仓位
然后你做着日线翻亚当的这个美梦
当然有可能成真
但是从1分K的单子
要突然间长大为日线的单
他中间要经过的那个关卡跟考验
太多了
所以更不容易达成
对吧
大概就是这种想法
好不好
所以你遇到的疑问
其实不是疑问
你只要坚持
我的计划就是我的计划
市场跟我的计划不一样的时候
骂他一下
骂市场一下
但是你还是做着你原来的计划
这样就好
问题不在你
问题也不在市场
在于你没有乖乖的做你原来的计划
计划是OK的
好不好
好
同學都問很多我看一下60K的兩條線什麼時候會随着行情去调整我看一下60k来看一下我的单子
这是我今天的单
我今天全部的单
你看在这边
那我们看一下60k
60k
我先把那个
拿掉一下
60k我来画线
早一点的60k
我这附近我没有画很精准的
但意思到了就好
所以早一点的60k大概长这样子
出现这样子的60k长这样子
到这样子的60k
嗯
在这个开门叫这附近
长这样子
但是经过这一根
我又回来到变这样子
而且下面很凶对吧
那现在60k就这样啊
你有沒有看到我都随意化
当然是随意化
因为
我只是在那个那个框框内
例如说我在我大概知道这个附近可能有东西
我只是在这个框框内等待我要的东西
等待他下不去
我大概是这种感觉
那实际上他会在这么大的框框
是500才停住
还是510 520 540 550
我不知道
那个等等他到时候到的时候市场会跟我说
他会在哪里开始出现一些边界
那你就看你要用多少錢多少次的失誤
去測試這個邊界
這樣
所以
就是調整
我就不會想太多大概就是
一目了然的看過去就是約略這個邊界
好不好
AVGO上週五買的給過嗎均價354
AVGO我記得我剛剛有先叫出來
AVGO在哪裡
A B G O
上周买的
这是1分K
吓死了
对了
上周买的
所以你是买在
我看一下
你是买在尖尖的这附近
354这附近
对不对
很漂亮
现在362
很好
防守包含的这个下雨线
可以
是说你现在的防守
应该已经不用包到这么远了
因为他开始出现了这个边界
但是你也不用拉很靠近哦
你大概就守到这附近就好
大概三百五十三四几这附近
把这个包进去就可以了
因为他在这个地方他会震荡
你就给他一点空间
是说其实离你原来的房属好像也不远
好啦 你先留在原位
等哪一天这边有这样子出去了
你再把你的房属拉到这附近
这样
好 那我就先往后看一下
看一下后面的东西
吃个股的停损是只要价格一打到就停损
还是要等多久
来这个是个好问题
来来来
一打到就要停损
还是要等多久
价格都不回来才要停损
这是一个千股以来一直得不到答案的问题
因为个股的停损
除非你是用券商的那种停损单
有一些台湾的券商有
有一些台湾券商没有
但是台湾的证券交易所
它本质上是没有停损单
好不好
所以你所有的停损单
尤其是个股的
他都是挂在券商的自己的伺服器上
条件到了
券商才在盘中帮你丢出去
你预设的那个交易的条件
那
我们就分两种
你有用
用系统设定的我就不管
因为那已经系统设定进去
你也来不及去变更
我们来讨论的是没有
没有系统设进去
你是人工的去执行停损的
那我就要问你啦
价格一打到不停損有两个情形
我不停損有可能弹回去
但是也有可能一打到就往下杀更多
那我问你到底要怎么办
这是一个永远没有解答的东西
因为可能今天是弹回去
另外一只股票是跌下去
再下一只股票又弹回去
再下一只又跌下去
哇
就是你得不到答案对吧
那我就要再回过头来问你
这些单子的停顺会有多痛
这是一个很重要的问题
因为如果这些部位在你的整体的资金里面
它是偏小
你说你要hold个几天
或是你下的部位小
你要等个一两天
还不回去停顺
OK啊
对吧
但是这一两天有没有可能遇到跌停又跌停
最夸张的就是连续两个跌停我是指两天内最夸张的行情如果你遇到美股没有跌停的限制那个就自求多福了
对不对
所以你没有办法说
到底哪一个好
但我普遍来说
我都建议
如果你的资本不够
那你没有那个闲钱跟闲时间
去跟人家凹单
跟人家玩逆向的摊品
因为你本职就资本不够了
你还跟人家玩摊品
人家可能摊个几次
他都没有差
但是我们摊一次回不来
哇就所有的账户就key掉了
就直接
酒菜就被割光光
我们没有那个能力
所以这个市场很现实
其实今天等一下也会聊到
就是
你会需要有一些资本来做
这会相对来的好
所以我的建议仍然是
一打到就直接先走
我宁愿你待会见回来
也不要你把那个犹豫的感觉放在心上
那个犹豫的感觉
我相信大家都有过
只要你把那个怀疑跟犹豫放在心中
你每一秒钟都会盯着行情
跳一动
然后你会跟着他一直
一直这样上上下下的跳动
手心流汗 心跳越来越快
肩膀怂起来
靠着萤幕越来越近
我讲的就是以前的我自己
各位干的事情我全部都干过
所以都是很白痴很笨的事情
遇到财报日跳空到停损线以下
甚至该闭嘴也停损吗
没有办法
我跟你说财报
财报是有个麻烦
就是你不知道他财报之后
有些时候是晃一下就往上喷出
有些时候是晃一下就继续往下
等下Peter说的对
因为我们无法知道这次的财报
他是怎么呈现
例如说今天往下杀
不代表明天会继续杀
也不代表明天会涨上去
所以这个很难去拿捏这件事情
所以最能够控制的
是你的交易计划
反而是财报会发生什么事
股市会怎么涨
川普会说什么话这都不是我们控制的范围全世界大概就川普的儿子有办法跟着市场的节奏走因为市场就是他老爸
大概是这样
讲讲今天的单子
可以
我今天的单
我今天的单长这样子
我今天有点一半一半
一半在乱做
一半在正常的做
这几单
是因为我这一单
我在这里出掉
我在这里
来到高点这里出掉
出掉以后后面喷成这样
超不爽
所以我这几单在接
但是我这几单接了
我花了两次的风险
然后发现不对
我在干嘛
好赶快收
收回来以后后面这边
我这里有试试看
然后这单就给它报出去
我今天的胜率才
我今天胜率只有18.75%
好惨
但是今天还是可以赚钱
有没有看到
胜率这么低
今天这种胜率对我来讲
这是
就是有比较乱掉的一天
大概是长这样子
对啊
然后我最大的一单是在这边
然后最大的亏损是192
平均亏67
平均赚194
这样子
而不对
Average Winning Trade
对不起是1082
我看错了
Winning trade是1082
然后Average losing trade是67
哇
这个比值就很棒
只是我今天胜率太低
我只有赚三次
最后一单来
我开图给大家看一下
这里吗
来来来
开细节给大家看一下
这边
我这边的部位
我不是大部位吃
我不是什么五口五口吃
我看一下这边有没有记录
应该有
只是他的时间
我觉得没有完全照着那个时间走
反正我讲解图好了
我在这边摸一下
发现他下来
下不去回来摸一下
再下不去再摸一下
然后我把我的防守
你们看到我的防守短短的
这边是多少
这边这样子十点不到
我这样加起来的防守10点不到
我后面这单是吃在这里各位觉得我今天吃到这里我的想法是什么把我打掉的这一根来把我打掉的这一根
理论上
应该是整个要下去才对
但是我却看到了
我却看到的是
是重要的边界
说回来的这件事
所以我那时候
我做了一个决定
好
吃
我最后这一单是五口
应该是五口而已
我看一下
几口啊
最后这单
对好像就是
对就是五口的
五口的这个这样子
所以我就是吃了五口
我本来其实还想说
五口吃了后面如果这里还有机会
再加个五口
结果就不回来
就干脆好算了就丢着
就这样啊
所以这是我今天
这边的教育
前面的我看一下前面的
前面的
等一下哦
早上7點那一段很棒啊
各位如果你仔細看喔
你看我下單的時候
我有沒有都在重要的邊界去測試
一早起來這邊
這是我人在一邊用著手機
想說試試看果然不要用手機下單
手機下單我覺得都會變得比較急躁
這裡
這些我覺得比較急躁
這個
你說老魚這個風行怎麼拉那麼遠
我這邊我記得好像只有下兩口跟兩口
就是我的风险
我还是把口数降得非常的低
这样
然后这个的概念
我也是打下去以后
一堆成交量理论上应该一路下去
却没有
那我就观察这一堆成交量
所建计出来的这个下影线这些边界
而且我也不是立刻就吃
我还多等了一下
下不去下不去好耶
吃一下看看
然后就这个就让我抱出去
所以
今天我的交易
正好是一个很好的案例
就是我今天是盲挥
闭着眼睛挥棒的盲见识
但是偶尔有挥到的几球
不小心都有让我做出去
就那三球
这样子
我今天的获利就
严格讲起来
其实就这两次
就只有这里跟这里
中间另外一个获利
我猜他应该是把我的不赔
当成是利润的
应该是这样
所以我就做这两次
这个喷出跑的瞬间
我为什么跑
第一个
我自己知道我今天有点急躁
我前几天也是这种感觉
想说好
那我就来到这个高点这边
真的都喷出了 我人刚好在这边
那就出一下 而且又有大量的成交量
这里 大成交量喷出
一堆人在这边买跟卖
那到底这边是谁获利呢
喷成这样子 我就趁着成交量跟着走掉
我看一下1分k我走在哪
我走在这里 走在这里
上去缩回来的地方这样
然后后面我就完全没有管他了
我就做我的
我的投影片
这样
好不好
我有同学有知道早上7点15那个
早上的那个其实很补啊
很补很补
来有人说停损大概抓几个Tick比较合理
我没有算过
我这样讲好了
例如说我在这边做停损
我在这边的停损就是这样子
这样子的距离
我不知道这样是几个tick
反正可能是目测20点吧
20点
那以小娜来讲
10口单我会赔400块
这样
那20点大概就是赔200块
好啊
我有200块的筹码跟你玩啊
OKOK
就这样子
所以我前面这边赚到了
然后中间这里乱玩
这个是带着这边的怒气
没有赚到的怒气
玩两次
好啦 缩手
缩手以后
我其实还有利润
就算在这个时候
我就算最后这单都赔掉
我当天可能应该还可以赚个700回家
我就是带着这个想法
这样子
所以最后这单补蛮多的
就这样
好啦 我今天的部位讲完了
所以不是几个Tick的问题
你今天可能防守三个Tick
哪一天防守五个Tick
17个Tick
25个TIC
这不是TIC的问题
是你距离有意义的边界多远
反正如果你吃得高一点
那你的停损自然而然就要远一点
因为有意义的边界在下面
那如果你吃得近一点
那当然这次的停损可能
所需要花的成本就不用很多
大概就是这样子的想法
这样好不好
人在外面用手机用什么程式我通常就是直接用网页网页开这个软体就这样你用网页开
各大券商就是这种
像我用的这个是Tradify的
你过去用那个TS也有
TS他有开他自己的App
你就用他的App这样子来下
或是你用网页版也都OK
好不好
好
那我们准备要开始起来
来讲今天的课程内容好不好
我投影片都还没开
大家等我一下
等一下
这个应该已经刚刚讲完了
我就不再继续讲
我开一下投影片
等我一下
来拉过来
好 这样子
来 今天的主题是这个
如何成为全职交易员
我为什么会用这个主题
因为我最近说到不约儿童
说到一些网友
对于全职交易员有一些想法
想说我要怎么样练
然后可以成为全职交易员
我觉得这是一个蛮值得跟大家聊的东西
来
我先回答前几天
就是有同学问到我的那个单子
到底为什么答
我先叫出来我的那个发文
有人知道这件事情吗
我现在是拿廖大帮我写的
我觉得廖大真的是我们的好朋友
因为他帮我把我要写的解答
全部就写给大家了
我看一下是找
我找到了
这一篇贴文来我拉过来
这篇贴文
这个我说跟儿子跑去游泳
这张图
我吃在这个地方
然后呢
我的1K在这
1分K在这
1分K这样子
那1分K在这边
我说我是在游泳池手机下的单
我不是在池里面
是准备起来的时候
拿着包包看一下手机
可以下来就按
按完我就进去洗澡去干嘛了
所以蛮多同学问说
歪歪的知道是关键边缘小格局里
好像没有看到尖尖的等等图歪歪的没有标准图吗等等那这个过程廖大帮我写了他的那我拉过来
这是廖大的
廖大直接
帮我写了我的心路历程
我的下单逻辑的确就是一个评分系统
假设满分100
我会去评估说
这里值不值得下单
那我心里面有个天秤在那边
大科度的边界啦
空方满足啦
有尖尖的啦
忍了一整天
我可以扣大出手
所有的这些
对
总分可能70分
真的差不多
70分70几分
你问我老鱼
到底是怎么算的
我没有精确啦
都马上是凭感觉
只是那个感觉会是
我会评估一下
这里有check
这个有check
大概是这种感觉
所以廖大直接解我的图
然后廖大还帮我写了一下
他一看到
这就是满足去的概念
然后在短线里面
他也整理得起来
而且很明显就是下不去
但我就看到下不去的地方
试试看
就这样子
所以人家都会问说
老鱼的发文怎么没有标准图
重点不在于有没有标准图
在于我看到的东西
我们看一下这个1K
各位你有沒有看到
这里有个下影线
你有沒有看到在这个地方
有个边界在这里
就是这些边界
所以我摆明就是在赌这个边界
我的防守就只有这样子
我就是赌这个边界而已
这样赌这么短短的边界
允许他
有同学说当时在等5K
我觉得我可能运气好吧
因为拿起来
我看一下5K看一下1K
好像可以下单
反正就算我要赔
注意这句话
就算我要赔
了不起就这样子给他
我是能赔到哪里去
我只要不要一直乱按就没事
对吗
那就这样子
回来
回来这个
这个是我回家的时候
我其实根本都已经忘记
我刚刚在游泳池那边有下这个单子
是回到家才看到
长上去了
不然就出一出吧
然后我刚按掉出场
我刚按完
行情就在我面前
不误会上去
能怎么办
不能怎么办他也有可能在我面前不误就下去对吧所以误会就是这样子OK
好了
那讲解完了以后
我再提醒所有同学
很多人会去研究说
老于你下单
为什么这里没有标准图
那里没有标准图
很多同学会陷入一个盲点
例如说我在某个地方下单
我可能是因为大颗度的边界很漂亮
怎么样我有我的评分标准
但是他可能只看到短刻度
他觉得短刻度没有图
老鱼你骗人
他忘记去思考到
我其实有更多其他不同的交易的逻辑
不是逻辑对不起
是图形放在我的脑袋
那他不知道
可能今天是15k的
可能明天是30k
可能后天是小时k的
我不知道
我要讲的只是
同学花精神去研究
老鱼的单下在哪里
其实是一点意义都没有
你研究十年
你还会是在研究老鱼也好
别人也好
网路上某个网友大大
或是有新的航海王
新的无人机王
新的什么王
我不知道
总之
你会去研究别人的单
你会变成是研究别人的单的高手
因为你研究了十年
但是要你自己下单
你屁屁刷
下得要死
因为你从来没有把心思放在
我的当下如何面对我的交易计划
做出我的风险承担
做出我的所有的事情
所以你会变成一个
很会讲技术分析的老阿伯
那什么都不会
还是赔一大堆钱
那是侃侃而谈
这样没有意义
所以我不觉得研究别人的单试
是有什么好处的
反而你把你的心思拉回来
例如说我打这些单子爆掉了
我打这些单子乱赔钱
那你就好好的把你的交易拉出来看
我到底做了什么事情
让我赔钱
一定有理由
那你能不能够在之后你自己的交易里面
改掉这些缺点
然后让你不会再度犯那个错
或是说你本来要花五天才会醒过来
你可不可以进化一点
三天就醒过来
再进化一点
一天醒过来
可不可以
所以這個
這個
我覺得不是
不是好的點
好的點是你要把注意力拉回到你身上
老魚做的單喔
幹關我屁事喔
对这样讲老鱼的单就对了
就是干关我屁事
这样就好
全部把交点拉回来自己的单上
好吗
来
全职交易员
其实真的是一种真正的职业
什么职业
在一些
我讲的是在最近的这些近年来
这种考试公司盛行之前
早就有了
在券商的自营部
各大券商台湾也有
国外也有
他们是什么
就是公司花钱请了一个
技术看起来不错
他们觉得你的交易能力
是可以帮公司赚钱的人
所以让你用公司的钱
刚进来的新人给你100万
试试看
你还OK哦
慢慢再扩大给你的扩大
给你200
给你300
给你1000
给你1500
给你5000
慢慢的
如果你不行
他就开始收回去你的资本
他发现你一直亏少一点给你
越亏就越少
所以你必须要证明你的能力给他看
然后呢
获利因为他有给你的基本的薪水
所以这时候获利怎么抽
就看各个公司不一样
大家的在关于抽成的这个制度
差异很大
好不好
就是不同的公司
不同的薪资的成本
其实你说跟保险业余不一样
也一样
你就是保险业请的员工
有底薪没底薪
防重也是啊
有底薪的防重抽比较少
没底薪的防重抽比较多
大概就是这个概念
你说风险公司扛
他也不可能无条件的扛
他就是会说
他觉得你变烂了
他觉得你的情绪控管很烂
他就开始说
给你的钱越来越少
少到某个程度就把你踢走
拜拜
你不符合他们要的人
这个是在
英国电视剧Industry
就是在讲这个行业
甚至更早期百万美金交易员
很早期的这个实境秀
他们也是在讲这件事情
所以很多人对全职交易员
电影里面拍的那种
他拍到的好多个荧幕的那种
然后坐在办公室穿着西装
打个领带在做交易
多半是像这种的全职交易员
他们是领人家的薪水
所以他的工作有没有可能随时就被fire掉有啊 如果他犯了一个大错金手指乱案或是本来要出10口变成出100口
那个会不会被老板骂
会有
他们都有风控机制
就是每个trader都有风控机制
越厉害的trader他会给你容许的风控机制
例如说他可以下到20口
更厉害一点的可以下到30口
再更厉害的下到50口100口
你是小咖刚进来就给你拾口试试看
大概是这样子
那我今天并不是要讲那种全职交易员
但是近年来
现在这些考试的公司
我们讲资金公司
自营公司
考试公司
有人讲什么道具公司
那个其实是翻译
英文叫做Prop Firm
反正就是他是使用
他没有钱
所以他们用那个方式在筛选
也借机在盈利
总之
这种公司的基本的营运模式
大概就是这样子
你有技术
或是你没技术都没关系
你用他的考试
然后去参加他的考核
如果你通过他的评分标准
他就给你账号让你做
做完了大家抽
做失败了
因为你还有付刷卡的考试费
所以做失败了
账号顶多就没收
就这样
他也不会要你赔那个钱
大概就是这样
好不好
金手指
等一下
知道家藤先生的人
现在年纪应该都跟我差不多了
对我们都没有证据
好不好
那个
他的第三个字的名字
我不知道他的名字是三个字还是四个字
我也不太认识他
好吗
来
请问你觉得他是全职交易员吗
这个
这位是谁
老八对吧
我是很怀旧的
好不好
我都不看新的片
我是很怀旧的这样
他算全职交易员吗
他跟你想象中的不一样吧
他做的是很长期的投资
而且他其实是有公司在帮他做
他还有接班人
你觉得他算吗
他是全职生活
他全职喝可乐的可能还差不多
对不对
他是感叠
再来这位最新的消息在8月份的消息而已裴洛西
大家都知道
他投资申报曝光
这一档AI电力股狂飙
你觉得裴洛西
他是全职交易员吗
但他有没有持有股票
有没有持有选择权
有没有赚钱
他蛮会赚的
他在7月24日到7月28号
分别买进Bloom Energy
那我们来看一下Bloom Energy的股价
长什么样子
我们来看一下
我这边有叫出来
来Bloom Energy
它在7月24号这里
跟7月28号
哇
这一天下沙买
不打紧
它再下沙继续摊平
再摊平
总共买了多少钱
总金额落在这边
1.3亿到4.6亿之间
靠这区间也太大了吧
对吧
来哦
我问你一件事
他们算全职交易员吗
你对全职交易员的想象是这样子吗
人家赚很多
全世界赚的比他多的没几个
而且他们有没有办法做到内幕
好像可以
现在在这里盘前269
而且人家还摊平
人家有资本摊平
你有吗
你要想的是这件事
而且他不是在他不是在从300跌到290
哇就开始摊平摊平摊平摊平摊平
我们一般人都是在这里就摊平
他因为一般人第一个部位买在这边
然后下来摊平在这里
第二个部位又买在这边
而第三个部位买在这
下来又摊平
所以这里还没真的跌破低点
已经摊平四次了
啊这个下影线摊平五次六次
再摊平七至八次然后被抬出去
然后全部被裴洛西接走
就长这样
这是我们一般人常见的摊品的样子
对吧
有人说他的资产介于
一万台币到一亿台币之间
我觉得他会算亚当
他买的点
同学说的对
他买在空房满足点
他真的会算
厉害
我不得不说
对吧
來
你覺得這位算是全職教育員嗎?這我是網路上查來的一個股市小白他無脑只是定期定额买台积电跟元大台湾50总投入成本169万9362
如今总限值601万
损益来到431万赚
你觉得他是全职交易员吗
人家什么都不知道
理财小白无脑买
哦对吧
所以你没有觉得大家好像对全职交易员好像有一个我觉得是错误的想象
好像你坐在电脑前面
啪啪啪啪啪
哦这边赚多少
哇那边赚多少
很风光一样
没有呢
这是完全不对的想法
这些人他们是不是全职交易员
也他自己也不在乎
他一样工作照做
回家一样洗衣服拖地
所有的事情都一样
但是他就是持有他的部位
有没有
所以这才是我觉得
我们身为在市场上
每天讨生活的人
你要想的一件事
市场并不是你坐在盘前越久
就一定赚得到钱
对吧
所以很多人他对全职交易
他都是一个感觉说
我以后要全职交易
Peter说这句话
从台股做到美股
本来白天也赔钱
现在晚上也赔钱
我怎么会有一个人在跳舞的感觉
Peter是你也有看过那个人跳舞的影片吗
就是讲这句话
好像不太对
那个人我们可能都认识
经典的反指标
来
所以很多人说
老鱼你可不可以教我
我想要全职交易
对吧
那全职交易
好了
你有什么计划
你愿意花多少时间
你这个过程
我说你要怎么撑过去
看来大家都看过那个影片
来
我为什么会这样讲
我说你有什么计划
计划是指全职交易
是一个大家的梦想
对不对
没有
大家其实不是梦想全职交易
大家的梦想是
躺在沙滩
钱就从天上掉下来
对吧
这是大家的梦想
只是你在工作的时候
你觉得你想要把老板fire掉
你想要把时间拿回来
看着旁边的全职交易的人
下午去全国饭店喝下午茶
好悠闲哦
去逛啦啦破好悠闲哦
我也要
你只是希望这件事情
对吧
来
你真的愿意牺牲
牺牲你的时间吗
很多人会说
他的工作
这样
他会说他的工作阻碍了他的做交易
但是你又需要这个工作来维持生活
哇
那你要怎么办
那我常常在这个地方
我会举一个例子是
大学要念四年
才会学成一个
可以在毕业后去某个公司就业的这个技能
或是知识
这样大学要四年
但是大家认为
交易好像只要一两年
哇好厉害
你可能刚好在去年逮到这一波
多大多头
你突然间就觉得自己满满的信心
觉得自己可以把老板fire 掉
我真的认识一些网友
就是认识的网友这样
他说他就把老板fire 掉了
结果最近他真的又回去找工作
为什么
因为当初那只是老天爷给了他一个运气
让他逮到某一波
可能逮到记忆体这一波
但是现在的记忆体又跟之前的记忆体不一样
虽然最近MU有长回来了
对吧
所以我其实觉得来回到上一章
要想要全职交易的人
你不能在一开始就把全职交易摆在心里面
你一开始摆在心里面
你永远做不好
所以你的计划是
好我给我自己
好例如说四年的时间
今年是2026年
假设我今天就是新手
我给我四年的时间
那我这四年呢
我要先借由工作来存钱
存到一个基本的额度的钱
额度多少
我没有办法给你一个定义
因为每个人的刻度都不太一样
每个人要负担的家庭的压力跟成本
也不一样
像我有三个小孩要养
三个小孩跟一个小孩跟没有小孩
每个月的花费就很明显不同
对吧
那你的计划是什么
这四年好
我要第一年我要做什么事
然后第二年要做什么事然后这中间我平常白天上班晚上我要花多少个小时来练习我的交易同时间你还要顾到家庭的平稳
你不能说跟老婆讲说我要研究交易
回来家事也不做垃圾也不到
地板也不拖
不能这样子
因为你这样子你的交易永远做不起来
对吗
所以这些不是一个单纯学技术
老鱼你教我技术
我要全职交易
技术其实都在这边
大家会的都差不多
旁边这些同学们
应该也觉得都差不多了
真正的重点是
你如何在这个技术跟家庭
然后各种断七八糟的琐事
取得那个平衡
你需要做到这件事
而这件事情
如果你把全职交易
全职交易这四个字
当成第一优先
你就永远达不到平衡
所以最一开始是不要
想着你想全职交易
你要想的是
好 我先求活下来
第一年的目标活下来
光能活过一年
你已经赢了八成九成的人
我很认真的说
就连大多头的时候
还是很多人赔钱
好吗
然后再来同学旁边说的对
这个金钱刻度的浮动
是我目前看过所有职业最夸张的
比医师还夸张
真的比医师还夸张
甚至厉害一点的
他一年的营业额是用千万跟亿来算的
一年赚到的钱
但是那个全台湾是有几个人
你也不用当那个第一名
不需要
我们当地一百名一千名都没有关系
一万名好不好
反正我就跟我自己比
我的第一年
我要求的就是我先活下来
光活着就好
因为你活着
你自然而然会找到
我哪些地方
我的情绪容易失控
礼拜一跟礼拜五
好
那我就礼拜一跟礼拜五
不要做交易
或是要做
做小一点
不然就是要亏损的话
设定一个比较紧一点的风控
我本來虧一千你會停手
禮拜一跟禮拜五虧五百就縮手了
好可以
如果是這樣子我給過
對吧
然後你會慢慢的去自己去修正你自己的缺點然後我這些地方我的優点很好我蛮会选股我蛮会报单好那我就继续的维持这些
一边修正缺点
一边维持这个
第二年第三年你会不知不觉
注意
不知不觉
跟刚刚那个小资族一样
不知不觉发现
原来我已经累积了一笔钱
在股市里面
在期货里面
这样 那个是不知不觉来的
你目的性越强 越做不到
包含你去考试 考这些自营公司的考核都一样
目的性不能那么强
NQ喷出去了是不是
NQ喷了吗
卖个贡
这里其实很好下单说
但是我那时候人不在盘前 算了
我有开我的
这是我现在在我的公司户的持仓
公司户的持仓这边
账号还是一样
还是我的公司户的账号
只是我现在暂时都先遮住
好了差不多了
目前持仓大概就这些
也不用管他
就让他继续走好了
今天MUU他们好像在动了
好就这样
有同学都忘记有单
忘记有单是好事
如果你在这里出
也是好事
又喷出一次
然后你又出场
这是好东西
那现在对做多的我来讲
我可能好一段时间
不会管小娜了
好不好
来再来
我们在讲
全职交易的时候
我们都忘记一件事情
交易的本质
是锦上添花
绝对不是雪中送炭
所以我刚刚前面讲的是
你第一年先活着的同时
你要先想办法在你的本业
你的工作上
先把它稳定下来
先把你的焦点放在说
我如何提高我的工资收入
我的业务收入
你是房仲就防止我如何多卖一些
你是保险
就是我保险如何多卖一些
对反正就是回到你的本业
你是炸鸡排的
你就鸡排多卖一些
对吗
我说锦上添花
大家应该听得懂
对不对
来你看看我讲的这句
你光爬出粪坑就需要使尽全力的人没有资格栽树上的苹果有些人一出生就有梯子一棵苹果树在这个地方
这里有苹果好几棵
有些人一出生他的梯子就这么高
他一伸手就有苹果可以拿
对吗
那有些人是出生在底下的洞里面
那如果你光爬出来你就要很用力
请你先花一点心思把那个洞补起来
至少那个地板要平稳
你才有机会往上跳往上爬这棵树
对不对
这棵苹果树好可爱
这已经是我的画画能力的极限了
这是我能画的东西
最漂亮大概就长这样子
好不好
那所以你在做交易的时候
我讲锦上天花给各位讲好了
我的部位
我很多部位我可以hold住
我可以凹单
我可以什么
因为你知道有资本的人
他其实可以很随意的去做这些事情
这边凹一下
像那个裴洛西
下沙爱摊平加码
而且加码的部位是几百万美金在算的
对不对
人家有能力接
因为他前面嘴壮很多了
但是有些人不是
所以那些
雪中送他
你都已经被埋在雪里的人
你的心思不应该花在
要透过交易翻身
你在网络上应该会看到好多
哇这个谁
这个交易选择权赚多少
哇那个谁选择权翻20倍
这个谁选择权翻300倍
300倍不夸张
真的有哦
但是那个是偶一为之
就这样子
那个不是常态
好不好
画风于卡索
有同学都快被洗掉了
有同学问我说这个开盘价
他这么凶我暂时不会理他
我刚刚不是叫你出一出
对啊
来各位请问
这一根要不要翻亚当这里
这里要不要翻亚当这里
要嘛
所以这个亚当翻出去怎么样
到这边已经怎么样
什么区
三个字
满足区
这样子到这样子
我把他们半透明
对吗
所以这附近
就是这种
来跟大家再度的重生
边界撞出去
瞬间说回来都不是好事
所以如果你底下我部位
其实直接出事
是很棒的
好不好
我现在没有打算要下多单
我现在带大家看一下
眼前的
这个60k出现在上边界
所以我现在在中间
在60k的上下边界的中间
我都不会理他
所以刚刚这个边界
我会先拿掉
因为他这么凶
对吧
那我就等他市场来到这附近
来到可能500到550之间
看他要干嘛
那我就等吧
那如果今天晚上我待会直播结束累了
等不到
等不到就等不到啊
就这样就好了
OK
这个我觉得我可以回答一下
有同学说教育会不会感觉
每一次的下单就像在泥潭上拔河
如果你有这个感觉
某个程度来说
你下的部位太大了
大到你会觉得很紧张
你才会觉得好像陷在里面
然后动弹不得
好像要拔河一样
代表你下的部位太大
我不知道你下多少
但是无论多少
总之不适合你现在的资金部位
就是我不知道多少
这样可以理解吗
你下的部位必须要轻松到
你可以很随意的
要砍就砍
你要轻松到这种角度
这样
所以我才会说全职交易
前面你不能直接先全职交易
我有遇过一个朋友
他有一次有私下跑来找我学
那个朋友他在
应该也不是朋友
就是一个学员
然后私下跑来找我学
然后他说我可以私下给你学费
这样就不要给公司私下找我学
那时候我还在公司
还在群艺
然后呢
我调查一下他的背景我就问他嘛我需要知道说他的生活上面的资金怎么样他说他们家族在冯甲有好几个店面而且都是便利商店的店面在收租金
他来找我的那天才刚去跟一个店面
签了五年跟全家签了五年的合约
这样子
然后他很好玩
这些人很厉害
他腰间都有一个腰包
我不知道为什么好像是他们的
固定的这种习惯一样
腰包一打开来一叠一叠的1000块用橡皮筋捆着的
各位应该有看过吧
这种就比大家比我都更有资格当全职交易员
因为他就算不交易
他一个月还是一直收租金
这间收一收那间收一收
他们家族每个月的资金租金收入破百万
每个月就这样子收收收
对啊
你觉得他是不是比我们更有资格
就算他亏钱
他没关系
下个月钱又回来了
他这个月亏50万
有没有关系
没关系
你懂吧
他有那个试错的成本
但是我们一般人没有啊
我们从底部爬起来的人
我们试错了一次就掉下去
然后跌很深
你还要再花十年的时间
再爬回来一次
你爬回来的这十年
你梦想着全职交易的梦想
但是你却还在还债
跟银行界的债
跟券商界的债
各种还债人生
然后你一直想要赚快钱
又再赌一次
又继续还债
对吧
所以不应该是用这种角度切入
我当时其实很羡慕他
因为他不用工作
他们家族就有100多
还是多少我不知道
反正就是超过100
他们家族就可以这样
我在那边赚老半天
对啊
那怎么办
没有办法
就只能靠自己
所以我后来的想法就是
人家在房地产上面有所掌获
那我就试着在我的股市里面
买我的房子
例如说在金融股里面
慢慢的盖我的房子
然后在电子股里面慢慢的盖我的房子
我在哪里哪里盖我的房子
大概是这样
要脱手也方便要买也方便而且还不会被扣各种房地的所得税那些对啊这不趁机敲一笔
来眼前的小娜是不是来到这边
但是这个60k真的很凶
我不觉得
我不觉得这边
不要哦
想要摸这个5k的人
你在这里摸被我打哦
好不好
你至少等他在这边走平了
像这里走平了
一个小时两个小时再说
好不好
你等他走平都不迟
所以要框起来有那个平
这样子
好吗
这个平长什么样子
我不知道
目前看起来他没有打算要停
我知道这边是重点区域
540这里
那你说我可不可以到1K
好到1K
那你也至少等1K走平吧
1K走个平
少说来个20分钟
30分钟
你的人生连这个都做不到
有同学说黄金有
破底翻是不是
黄金哦
黄金有吗
来
黄金
看一下
黄金现在是Z6吗
黄金多少
5K吗
这里吗
一样哦
有点凶 上面斜斜下面平平的
这个5K破底翻等一下等一下
对 等待区域目前有点宽 我还不知道在哪
因为你看哦 这里有好几个下影线来碰这边
虽然这边有这个边界 但是下来的样子很凶
我看一下60K好不好
来 我跟大家讲一下
我不喜欢60k的下影线被吃进来的这个边界
我不喜欢
我喜欢的是60k的影线
刚好它落在这个边界就出去的这种
它只要往下影线的里面
隔壁这边往下影线的里面吃进来
像这个的这个点
我做的都常常都亏钱
这样
所以我觉得这个点没有很爱
好不好
黃金的長線就整理了起來 目前是這樣子 我也還不知道
對感覺有點爛掉了
短線的5K 我剛剛是不是才在講我剛剛是不是才在講黃金的5K K不要急有没有我刚刚是不是在这里我就花斜斜的平平的有没有还好大家好听我的对吧
不要急
这个边界你等他一下太凶了
你至少等一个5K
例如说像这样子
假设待会有一个5K长这样子
长在这里
你出现这样子的隔壁
在这个地方再来下单
都不辞
拜托
如果有这样子在下单都不辞
忍
忍忍忍
在市场上
不是做越多
做在荧幕前面越久
就赚钱
刚好我下一张投影片
谁说要一直盯在盘前才能赚钱
这也是大家对于全职交易员的迷思
你看到的电影
好像
就是要这样子盯在盘前
哇这个做到天然气
那个做到原油
然后这个做到什么
这个做到小纳
那个做到美股
台积电也做到
你下越多单真的保证每一单都赔钱吗
所以你在盘前越久
不代表
不代表每个都赚钱
所以人家说
大家网友写的
每多个萤幕赔钱速度就会快一倍
我的萤幕不是长这样
我的萤幕只有两个
就這邊一個 旁邊一個就兩個
而平常我在看盤的時候
我就一個螢幕而已
我旁邊的螢幕是在看影片
我最近在追那個
很久以前的美劇
那個Smallville
很拖啦
但是就看了下去就一直看
所以旁邊在追劇
或是在看其他東西
然後反正頂多就一個螢幕而已
就這樣
我跟你說
螢幕的多寡根
会不会赚钱一点关系都没有
一点都没有
好不好
我曾经有在
那时候我还在券商里面
然后券商就配给我一个座位
然后有萤幕这样子
我曾经有四个萤幕
那我发现
其实我也没有很常看那四个萤幕
我就还是看我常看的这些
这样
OK
在我FB上面应该偶尔会有
你找之前的照片
我应该有拍过我的桌子
就是就是这边一个萤幕
这边一个萤幕
然后这边是钢铁人跟跟那个那个
那个什么
哎我好像现在可以拿起来给大家看
长这样
看得到吗
这样子
这是我旁边的东西
对
OK
所以就是两个萤幕
然后跟钢铁人这些这样
看得到吗
应该有
所以就这样而已
我今天之所以会用这个全职交易当主题
是因为太多人问
而且这个过程中好多人好多人问我
这个有关于全职交易的问题
我觉得不是你可不可以
而是那个时间点会自己来
你可以做好这个计划
我想要往这边走
OK
我想要用交易帮我赚钱
好那我就做好计划
亦步亦趋慢慢的来
交易有很多个拼图
什么
就是说判断压力支撑的拼图
实际上下单的那个尖尖的拼图
出厂的拼图
有好多种交易计划的拼图
你每学一个
你需要一段时间把这个拼图给内化
然后同一时间你的脑袋跟你实际上
实体生活上的金钱跟生活的平衡
也需要在这个过程中找到你的均衡点
所以所有的这一切
全部都要搭在一起
你知道吗
那在这个过程中
你要抱着做爽的练身体健康的方式来练
你太给他那种目的性
你很快会尝到很多苦头
但是你一定要先尝过
我跟你说这里有洞
你一定要先跳过
你才会说对这个坑不能跳
你要先痛一次
可能两次可能三次
所以你在这个过程中
你会慢慢知道
原来我不需要盯在盘前
我不需要那么多萤幕
其实也可以赚钱
我刚刚之所以拿出那个
小知足
只是纯0050跟买台积电
平常都没在看盘
我之所以拿那个出来跟大家讲
是因为每个人都有生活
都有家庭
都有小孩
各种事情
对吗
还要工作
你不可能就直接
把自己当成一个全职的交易者
事实上
你是不是全职交易者重要吗重要的是我的部位长期下来可以帮我赚钱这才是大家要的根本吧我户头你的股票长期下来可以让我退休
可以让我多一点钱
可以让我过退休的生活
不用烦恼工作
这是大家想要的吧
对吧
你不能在现在就想说
你明明都还做不到
就直接想着那个愿景
然后把家庭给放掉
不行不行
所以真正你知道在网路上
最会跟你自称
你好我是某某交易者
你好我是国外法人的交易者
网路上最会跟你自称
他是某某机构某某基金的交易员
的是谁吗
诈骗集团
我才不在乎我是不是什么trader
我每天在外面穿的都是这样子
有些同学在外面会遇到我
会捕捉到我
他看到的我大概就是这种穿着
那我会跟你说你好
我是交易员老鱼
不会啊
谁理你啊
我就只是老鱼
只是碰巧
会有一些交易的技术
而且还都不用钱啊
我就交给大家
是吧
我只在乎的是我的生活
我的人生
我是不是交易员
逛屁事
你懂吗
我的股票我在赚钱
我的部位有在赚钱
好这样够了
那我的生活也顾得到
然后我的工作也顾得到
好像都可以
这样就好了
好不好
然后再来我一定要讲一件事
请不要在有金钱压力的情形下
直接就全职交易
例如说现在
如果你把我手上所有的收入都拿掉
然后丢一个台币100万给我
然后叫我说老鱼
你所有的收入都拿掉哦
没有任何收入
然后你用这100万开始赚钱
你知道我就完蛋了吗
我立刻100万
我大概一个月就赔掉给你看
可能不用一个月
要赔很快的
为什么
我有小孩要缴学费的压力
要吃饭的压力
各种杂七杂八的压力
对吗
那这压力压在我身上
我当天就有不得不赚钱的压力
完蛋了
这压力一来
什么厉害的交易法都没有用
你就是会乱做
对
大家应该都有这种经验过压力一来就是会乱做这真正的重点根本不是在什么交易技术我一直跟大家讲你需要建立轻松打单的感觉
这个才是所有交易的最根本
所以刚刚有同学问我说
他会有那个深陷泥沼里面
然后把那个跟泥泞里面拔河的感觉
有没有
那就代表你下的不会太大
或许你的资金面还没有准备好
那个准备好不代表是你要下单哦
那个准备好只是你有这样子的钱
反而你的心会
我们台语讲就窄很稳定
那个有钱才有胆是真的
这样好不好
NQ差不多了吗
真的吗真的吗
来我们看一下我们东西可以吃
NQ
可以耶
防守防守这边
5K吃的有点急
但是1K好了随意
1K就守这边吧
看了掰了
掰了
准备掰
果然还是不要乱吃
仗着前面有利润
随便乱按就是这样子
这个完全没有图
我是看了就看了大家讲
我就我就按了
交友软体上的妹妹都很会投资
有头绪吗
你就把他约出来
虽然我肯定都约不出来
说不定背后是肥宅
对不对
跟那个一级玩家一样
网友见面到最后
大家都是男生
好像可以
那我跟你说
我现在看到EK这样子
对不对
我这里会再补一个部位
这个部位
然后防守基本上也差不多就是在这里
对就是这样子
SMR开始喷了
那我多补部位的想法
就是我再赌他这个1K的这里会撑住
如果撑不住我就两个停损
停损这样全部停损可以多少
假设全部停损会赔200200多
可以啦给你
这样
那如果这边就赔掉了
我今天就不干了
我就这样子
来同学旁边如果要问问那个旁边同追女生也是这样 不能太有目的性
看那么多萤幕的也是看监视器的
我停损了 谁可以吃的
Vincy 我停损了 你准备可以吃的
这个是个好问题
我可以回答一下
来
有同学说
存了三年的生活费
没车贷房贷
没女朋友
没老婆小孩住家里
想要全职打TS
有通关过
可以给你一些建议吗
来我给你第一个建议
先去参加一些活动
先交一个女朋友再说
第一个
你想要全职打TS
你会变得太有空
你会太有空
代表你每天都在盘前
我曾经有教过一个同学
他很年轻
然后他说他一天有16个小时可以看盘
也就是说他除了睡觉以外
醒来的时间都在盘前
我说不行你太有空
太有空就像我这样子
随意的就按一按按一按这样子
然后呢
你太有空的情形下
你全职打
我肯定你一定打不过
所以你先抱着不要全职的这件事情
好不好
你很棒
没有车贷
没有房贷
对吧
那你现在要做的是
你先把你的工作照样的继续给它稳定
Vincy可以吃了
就这里
我刚刚答应我自己不能吃的
所以我不能吃的
Vincy这个是一分K可以吃的点
就是这里
就这个
这个吃点是我平常会吃的点
这样
好不好
然后你说你还没有出经过
可以给你一些建议吗
有通关没出经过
那你就要问自己了
如果你都可以通关
但是却无法出经
这两个之间的差异在哪
是不是你通关拿到账号以后
你给自己太多的
心理压力又是那个目的性
因为你一通过以后
你就会想着
我要出金
你想的事情就会是这个
你刚刚有吃的可以拉不赔了
你想的就是我要出金
我要出金
所以你会一直被他困住
最好的方式是你既然可以通关
代表你做对的某些事
你只要在通关之后继续维持着你原来做对的事情继续做
然后你也不要管能不能出金都不要管
你就是继续做你原来的事
一天两天三天花个30天好不好
一天赚100块美金花个30天
我讲的是平均30天下来你才赚3000美金
很少啊
网路上人家po什么一天就赚3万美金的
你管他了
就慢慢做你的
我们是管那个细水长流的
而不是在管说我瞬间就要喷一根
然后让大家爆赚的这样子
所以第一个建议去交个女朋友
真的好不好
拜托真的会你转移了这个注意力以后
心思拉到女朋友以后
把交易当成是闲事
兼职的
闲闲的做闲闲的做
这样就好
好吗
日常还有在静坐跟冥想吗
有
时间不一定
但是就是我会自己找生活上面的一些空档
这样
所以
引线后
那个
手引线后面是对的
那个是对的
这里的防锁点吃在这边黑队就是守这里
这个防锁超短啊
这是我平常很会打的单子
反而不是这两个
交女朋友更花钱
就代表你还是需要把心思放在原来的工作上
你总是原本有个工作吧
心思放在你原来的工作上
如果你原来的工作是固定薪水的工作
你就想办法升职
想办法往更高的阶层爬
或是你只好
如果那个薪水爬不上去了
那你就只好去兼职
让自己
我讲的兼职是工作
先花一点时间累积金钱
没有办法
我们年轻人只能用时间换金钱
那累积到了某个程度
其实你自己会知道
然后在这段期间
请你用兼职
不要全职的方式来打TS
你要打哪一間的我覺得無所謂
你就是打這個然後你就是照著我剛剛跟你講的你能夠出金都不要管你能不能够出金都不要管你怎么通关的
你就用同样的方式
完全不要管这个账号是通关也好
是练习也好
是什么账号
你就是正常的照做
这样好不好
有同学说每次冥想多久
冥想哦
不一定
有些时候五分钟而已
因为生活上各种事情其实蛮多的
我比较常有冥想的时间反而是早上
因为早上像我要工作
我要看盘之前
我在我的书房
我老婆知道他会给我一点空间
所以我可以在这边
就是好好的静下来
可能十几分钟吧
我没有真的去精算
其实我自己心里面知道
就是静下来一段时间
差不多了
这样子
OK
来旁边
有同学问002594
这是什么东西
应该是中国的东西
这个吗
这件件的很漂亮
在小时k下三层
什么叫下三层
三层
你的发音是这个吗
不对我写错了
完蛋了
我不会写字
三层
可以啊
这个尖尖的很漂亮
可以
有人会说他把优雅拿来搭配冥想
这个是偏方
我不知道有没有用
不过我知道的是
你很容易升天变成圣人
这样子
这个倒是我知道的
RKLBR
昨天收盘前建仓
昨天收盘前建仓在这里
虽然图还合格的摸吗
如果你是用周线的摸
我会给过
因为你前一个周线是长这样子
这个边界这个周线长这样我会给过
但是如果你是日线的
收盘前除非你的风险其实就是这样子你做的你吃这边防锁底下其实你在做的就是周线的单因为你把前一周的这边
整个这个当下引线来做
这样我会给过
OK
我在猜你应该是有看到
这么远的这种周线的刻度
你才会在那个地方建长
周K是可以的打击区吗
我没有打错
对不起
这个才对
周K吗
是可以观察打击区的位置吗
可以
但是它短线来的样子
有点凶
所以我会想要在这边等一个什么
等一个
这样子的动作
那你会在周K等到
还是日K等到我不知道
目前的日K我看一下
日K也还没有
包含这个都还是
比较容易下杀的K棒
你最好等到像这种K棒
长在这里
最好是破
最好再破一下
把这个打破再收回
这个很棒
如果是这样子就相对好很多
好来
今天买18.85会不会太摸
2208我还没出手
我已经在观察了
我还没出手是因为
它没有任何一个日线
是我刚刚讲的这种
像这样子
我在等这件事情
我还没等到
如果它明天有破
我反而会更爱这件事情
所以你今天买18.85
我是觉得
还没有到值得出手的样子
因为你的前面没有任何一个
这种下引线帮你撑腰
你知道吗
所以现在的这个就有点硬
NQ下去了
我刚刚应该有
叫大家吃的人要拉不赔对吧
那你至少有不赔啊
对吧
那现在回头看
还好我用短风险就玩过这个
我也没有跟他凹单
如果我凹单
如果凹丹也凹完了好开心,现在就在哭了
买在500亏在400亿不要了,这张图我没有到很爱我知道是周线的大边界但他周线也不美丽所以我还在还在等
这样
Netflix
Netflix相对起来不错啊
这个下山很好啊
大边界一样
在这种边界区域你都是等等什么
对等这种下影线
好不好 Google
来 Google
Alphabet
还能称吗
这样讲好了
你问还能称吗
是问我还能称吗
还是问你还能称吗
不对啊
你的交易计划应该是留在你的身上
不应该是我来告诉你还能称吗
如果你都要用称这个字
代表你应该已经撑不住了
现在就直接走吧
如果你认为你要用撑这个想法
因为如果你是原来就已经有计划的人
其实不应该要用
我还要不要撑住这个单子这样
应该就是我就照我的计划
跌下来就赔啊
对吧
如果没有跌下来
没有达到我的停损
我就抱着啊
应该就是这样子而已
你是买在周线
所以你是买在周线的这边吗
如果你是买在周线的这里
不错啊
如果你是买在周线的这边
这周目前快要破了
你要破的走也OK啊
因为它目前看起来也没有很漂亮
对啊
理论上这周的这个下影线
隔壁应该要这样出去才对
但是却没有
同学说刚回来用姿态激进
没关系没关系
没关系
这个都小事
那个love同学
love in trade
1k下引线
NQ60k
不要啦
那个
忍一下忍一下
现在的波动的程度有点大
忍一下
你等5k都不迟
真的
你等这个5k停住
现在还有一分钟停住
5k停住的隔壁再来做都不迟
不是现在
所以他刚刚在这里
等他停
哇!这隔壁有点高
因为他的边界在下面
在这里
所以他刚刚在这里
它稍微收
这里不好防守
因为你守这边也不对
比较正常的防守是这里
所以刚刚这里我觉得太高
不好守
它这个下影线收得太出去
所以不管你吃在这边的哪里
你必须要守的点是这里
哇 有点远
你可以吃
但是就是那个风险
就是拉到这里去
这样子大概有
哦 四五十点的风险
这样
对 这图真的有点少
哦来2308
我部位还在啊
部位还在啊
因为我的军架在这边啊
我没有什么加码
就在1700这附近这里
所以我没有
我没有什么加
我就抱着而已
我也没有要看嘛
就抱着
我没有什么想法
也不觉得说他会
会一次就上去
也不觉得说他会跌很多
我目前就是在这边鬼混
就让他鬼混
就这样子
我这里还在
我四张都还在
我君教就在这里
在这附近
什么时候要包
来
有点搞不清楚
我用刚刚的小娜来讲好了
因为破底番
如果这个破底番要成立
你看刚刚我是不是讲来了
对不对
所以如果你要吃
如果你要吃
刚刚你看一下这个地方
在1K其实看得很清楚
刚刚短线的5K其实涨到这边去
跑到这边去
但是这边才是市场在乎的边界
所以如果你刚刚在460这里
这些地方
这才是市场在乎的边界
你距离你的防守是不是就很近
那刚刚的那个5K
什么时候要守短短的
很简单
例如
我想一下我要怎么举例
例如这边上去
我借我组合一下
刚好这个借我用
例如5K不要吃
这个下雨线吃进来图很烂
没有很漂亮
假设图是这样子
上去的又回来了出现这样子
然后隔壁这里出现一个像这个组合
像这样子
已经是在边界上了
这个边界也是破底翻的边界
而且我都画了出来
这里有一个这样子有没有十字线这个我如果在这个十字线的隔壁吃,我就守他的下面就好了因为他的这个本身就是这个你听得懂我的意思吗
十字线在这里,在这个地方,十字线
我就守吃丹的这个的下影线这个地方,因为他就是他
但是刚刚的图不一样
刚刚的图是在这个最上面在这里
你吃在这个地方其实如果你是5K来讲
你的防守还是要拉到这种地方
说不定刚刚就被点掉了
我刚不是说吗
这个5K在这个位置太高
他这个引线收得太高
一来就来到隔壁容易被撞下来的这些地方
这样可以理解吗
好不好
有要握本钱玩
但是我觉得现在我看一下
好了前面这个1K好像可以
再玩一次好了
没吃到
这样子
如果是像我现在
我吃的这样子
我就只有守这里就好
这里就这个
这个就是我这个边界
边界我引线这里
我就是守这个东西
守这个边界
那1466
然后防守448
这样
这个赔掉了
就不玩了
如果获利的
我是不是可以先把我的利润
我一个部位先吃在这里
我觉得我今天好像都是看到网友说
我可以吃我就吃
结果这样都赔钱
还好啦
我的第一个部位
可能这边就先走五口
然后第二个部位
如果这边让我走到五口
我就可以承受这个震荡
下一个部位就是挂开盘价吧
就这样子
这是我目前的防守
第一个出场
第二个出场
我都乱拉的
反正大概就是这样
那5K呢
是不是
5K哦
有点像
它现在就有点尴尬
就是我看到有人在抵抗
但是它又在斜斜的
所以在这个抵抗的过程中
它其实扫荡的速度算快
你不觉得吗
有没有
一下子上一下子下
我要被点掉了
看来今天
我觉得我以后应该还是不要看大家下单我还是乖乖等我自己的下单好了你看今天这样子哇本来
本来2300的
现在剩1600
不行不行
应该要这样子收手就好了
今天下午6.55k
好啦我再回答一些
一些问题我就准备要下课
现在10点10分了
我们家小编真的每次都在念我的
因为他的工作越来越多
哦如果我刚刚停在5K多好
我如果刚刚停在5K
你知道
这个尖尖的隔壁
才是我平常5K会
会做的动作
对我证明了别人的话
听听就好了真的是
如果这个5K收这样子
这个才是我平常最喜欢的东西
是 我刚没看到
因为大家留言洗很快
我可能没有看到
不要不要
我不要吃了
我等一下要睡觉
我今天就这1600睡觉
我不要了
我不要再吃一次
不要不要
如果就算这一单能够让我赚很多
也没关系
我就这样睡觉
我还是赚1600
至少我的户头
你今天就是比昨天多1600
好可以了可以了
这样
好不好
来
所以
一个好的交易员
要知道自己今天的状况
We all have bad days
我今天
其实本来我今天状况还OK
这是刚刚突然间
变成一个状况不对的我
我是說真的
一個好的交易員
你觀察自己的狀況
是一個很重要的事情
其實說真的
如果我今天沒有再跟大家直播
我可能不會切到短線去看這些
我應該就是乖乖的停在5K
然後旁邊看我的影片
我說我在追那個small view
應該是這樣子
對
我就是證明上下震盪要幫手
早上八點算破底翻嗎?
好想笑!不行!
早上八點八點這裡嗎?你講的是這個對不對?這邊嗎?現在看有點好像像對不對?
但是實際上當下會有點尷尬
我們當下在這邊
不容易下單
因為他衝到這裡去
又是滿足區
又是壓力支撐這樣子
不容易下單
對啊
好不好
你知道我現在
心里面的那个不爽的感觉
越来越多了
我察觉到
我应该要关直播了
有有不爽的感觉了
这个不爽的感觉大概就跟这个一样
就跟这个一样
这样
其实我如果停在我平常看的5K
其实没事
不要不要不要
好了
准备要下课了
好不好
那我同学旁边问的问题
如果要要问更多
你可以写信到那个老鱼的金融笔记的那个FB
我会看得到
只是大家留言会比较多
我不见得能够立刻回得到这样
然后呢
今天我要讲个好笑的事
因为今天系统那个FB的系统
他就突然间跳出一个说
你要不要试用那个AI回讯息这样
然后我就想说
好不然我用AI看看这样子
然后呢
来我
我看一下哦
就是有同学就
传给我
我把对方的那个名字遮一下
我这个一定要跟大家分享一下
超好笑
那时候我就开了AI的聊天
然后这些都是AI帮我回的
这样
然后同学就说老一不会干这种事情啊
干嘛的
这其实是AI
我只是在玩玩看AI发生是怎么样这样
然后呢
AI还会这样子讲
还会说
你说的对老鱼绝对不会加你的
也不会贷单或要求汇款
所以最后我就回给他
就是我遮一下他的个子
这些
来这才是真正的我讲的话
我说我是那个喜爱优雅的老鱼
就大概是这样子
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕